I'm John Stirlmeyer and I am a troop order of the Aero
Representative Advisor with Troop 55 in Houston, Texas.
This edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast
is sponsored by backers like me.
Clark, thanks so much for all you do with the podcast.
It certainly makes everything a lot easier.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
So
two fellows are out kayaking and they're getting cold, but
they still have a long way to go. so
they stop by the shore, they get what they need for a fire and
they decide that to drive off the cold, they're
going to build the fire right there in the kayak. So
you know, they get back on the water, they
build the fire in the kayak and,
of course, you know exactly what's going to happen: The
kayak lights on fire and they sink. So
it only goes to prove what we all knew already: You
can't have your kayak and heat it too. You
can't have your kayak and heat it. Oh,
Hey,
listen. This
is podcast number 254.. How
about that? I'll
get it. I'll
get it, Hey.
Welcome
back
to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is
Clark Green. Let's take
a look at the mailbag We heard
from Rick Kolakia Jr, who's a Scoutmaster with Troop 750, and he
says: Thank you
for all the effort that you put into your regular postings. They work
well for us as in-service training. I read
the post about the Scoutmaster conferences. The Scoutmaster
conference frequently asked questions and I
was surprised you didn't include the content from a
new Scoutmaster training syllabus specifically in
the appendix G-N-H- the best
official explanation of the Scoutmaster conference I've ever
seen. Well, Rick,
thanks for alerting me to that. I had
kind of breezed through the new Scoutmaster training syllabus and
I really hadn't seen those appendixes. but I
went and reviewed them and you're right, They're very,
very good. So I'll
make sure, since that training syllabus is available as a
PDF, I'll make sure to put a link to that in the post that contains
this podcast. And, once
again, if you're interested in what Rick's talking about,
it's in the appendix G-N-H in that
document. Paul Gilbert
got in touch and said I saw
your site mentioned on Facebook. I hope
you don't mind. I downloaded,
I downloaded.
I downloaded
your Woodcraft and not PDFs. Thank you
very much. By the
way, I was a Scout many years ago and enjoyed
it very much. Well, I'm
happy when anybody gets something out of
what we've made up and anybody's
welcome to use those PDFs. Jason Almeider
is with Troop 370 in Sandy Hook, Connecticut. He said
I just listened to podcast 123. as I
binged my way through the archive I almost
had to stop the car over the log story. Okay, so
I had to go back and check up on that. I was
pretty sure I knew what Jason was talking about. There's a
story on podcast 123 from summer camp years ago and log,
and if you're a Ren and Stimpy fan, you know
the log song. And if
you're not a Ren and Stimpy fan, well, you'll
just have to give me a moment to talk
to the other Ren and Stimpy fans out there. I was
roughly college age when Ren and Stimpy was popular and now
my wife and I still occasionally quote things from that
cartoon show to each other. Oh yes,
Ren and Stimpy, Thanks for
all you do on the podcast. It's helping
this new Scout master tremendously Well, thanks
for getting in touch, Jason. I really
appreciate it And I'm
glad that we share Ren and Stimpy in common. Hey, let's
see, We had
a live chat this week. Wow, we
had a lot of folks on the live chat this week and I
am really happy with the way that's going. We will
go ahead and set up a live chat. Most of
the time it's on weekday mornings. Watch the
Scout master cgcom Twitter feed and Facebook
feeds. I'll announce
when I'm going to be on live, And this
week. wow, that's a lot of names: Terry Gerard,
Ray Britton, Dave Smiley, George Z, Rob from
Muskego, Randy Carpenter, Mike Meninger, Dale Austin,
John Nelson, Adam Cox and Bill
McFarland. all checked in And you
know we discuss whatever comes up, So come
on in, Say hi
and join in the live chat this week. Hey, I
mentioned this last time around. I'm going
to keep pushing you on this. How are
your high adventure trip plans coming along? You're going
on a high adventure trip this summer, right? Every
scout
should have the opportunity to be able to do that, And
I
know everybody senses that. it's an experience that is really great
for scouts And it's
a lot of fun too. If you
look at the numbers, most of us don't really even get started.
We may
think it's too expensive or we don't have the time or the
skills or the confidence to get the ball rolling, But the
open secret of it is many troops and crews do make
their own plans And they
have their own high adventure experiences with their
scouts, and they do it on a regular basis. So I
want you to think about that. There's lots
of resources on the blog that will help you. go to the
index, look for the outdoor program, look for high adventure,
and we'll help you get started thinking about that,
And I'm
happy to help by answering questions or providing whatever direction
I can for you to get your high adventure program
moving. Every scout
ought to have a high adventure experience. All they
need is someone to make it happen, and that person is
you. So let's
get moving right. I will
be at the Area 6 Spring Workshop on Saturday, March 21st
at Cecil College in Northeast Maryland, And this
workshop is designed for people at the district and
the council level, So I'll
be there talking about unit-based high adventure, And I
also want to mention that Condorsteg, Switzerland, is
one of the finest places in the world to
have a great high adventure experience and a mini
international jamboree at the same time, And I'll
be headed there in the summer of 2016 and I would
love you to come along with me. So get
in touch with me and we'll start talking about exactly
how we can make that happen for your scouts. So
if
you're a regular reader and listener and the resources that
we've created at ScoutmasterCGcom have helped
you, you can return the favor by becoming a
backer. The money
we get from backers goes to the expenses of producing and
publishing the blog posts and the podcasts and
all of the other resources that we create, and
those backer funds help us keep them online and
accessible for scouts all over the world. Now it's
a pretty easy thing to do: Go to
ScoutmasterCGcom, Click the
support link at the top of the page. You can
choose any level of support, including those that
entitle you to an autograph copy of one of
my books or all of my books. And this
is the time where I thank people who signed up
within the last week to become a backer, and we've
had a really active participation in the backer
program since the first of the year. But this
week I don't have anybody who signed up since
the last podcast. So do
me a favor: If you've
been waiting, go on over to ScoutmasterCGcom, become a
backer this week and I'll be sure to thank you
in our next podcast, podcast 255.. In the
remainder of this podcast, we've got a couple of
email questions to answer. I don't
see anything preventing us from doing just that,
So let's
get started, shall we? There's a
quartermaster everybody knows. There's a
song about him. This is
how it goes. Just a
little diddy doesn't mean a thing, But when
the boys are marching how they love to sing, There were
mice, mice eating up the rice in the stores. in
the stores There were
rats- rats big as blooming cats in the quartermaster's-
Big as
blooming cats in the quartermaster's store. My eyes
are dim. I cannot see. I have
not brought my specs with me. I have
not brought my specs with me. Write me
a letter, send it by name Email. that
is folks. And here's
an answer to one of your emails. I had
this email from David who said I had
a scout who submitted a completed merit badge
application from a merit badge he had done at
one of these merit badge exposer clinics. And in
this situation, I knew that there were a couple of
requirements that could not have been completed at
the merit badge clinic And I'm
not quite sure how to address that. Furthermore, I
want to know if we can bar scouts from attending
merit badge clinics like this or just
review the requirements, Not that
we would retest them, but that we would review them
with them after the clinics, because this seems
to be an ongoing problem. Well, David,
if you think there may have been a problem with
the counselor at the clinic. let's not
make the scout responsible for something that an
adult might have done improperly. Now I
would say that 99.999% of the time when we receive
a completed merit badge application with the
counselor's signature on it, we go
ahead and we get the badge and we give it away.
This is
a really rare occurrence where you understand, you
have direct knowledge- that there was a
requirement that could not have been completed in
the context of the clinic. I understand
that might happen occasionally. So we
don't want to ding the scout because a counselor
got something wrong. What we
want to do is we want to make sure that the
folks who are responsible for certifying counselors
know that there was a problem
in this particular instance. Those are
the folks on your district advancement committee.
They're the
ones who certify counselors and it's
their job to follow up on any concerns. Now there's
a way of doing this. There is
a form in the Guide to Advancement 2013 called
Reporting Merit Badge Counseling Concerns. That
way,
you can take, fill that form out, make sure
it gets to your district advancement folks and
get them to follow up on that particular concern.
The way
the Merit Badge program is set up, the final
word on completion of requirements is
up to the counselor. They're not
subject to our review. The counselor's
signature is the final word on the
completion of the requirements. Now, if
you'll read the Guide to Advancement, Section 7
on Merit Badges, and specifically the part
of that section which is 7.0.4.7,- the
limited recourse for unearned
merit badges- You'll better
understand how those things are administered.
I'll add
that this should be a very rare type of
thing that happens and I would never recommend
that you restrict the scout's choice
of counselors or venues like these
Merit Badge clinics or things like that,
and I would not recommend reviewing what
happened there, whether you want
to call it a test or not, because the
counselor signed off and a review of
what was done during the Merit Badge
is really not a part of the process. What
you
can do if you have direct knowledge of
something like you have described, is
follow the procedure that I've outlined
here and that you'll find in
detail in the Guide to Advancement 2013..
And I
heard back from David he's going to follow
up on that with his district Advancement Committee
and make sure that things
get taken care of there. I also
received this email. I need
some advice on dealing with a scout
who has been bullying other scouts. I
believe
the bullying is a desire for attention that
he's probably not getting at home.
His main
outside activity is scouting and I
believe it's something that he needs. but
we just can't allow this kind of
behavior. My game
plan at this point is to consult with
our troop committee chair and
our former scout master first, but
I feel that I need to have a
scout master conference in order to
let this scout know how to deal
with this behavior. I'll also
tell him I won't approve any rank requirement
until he can display proper scout
spirit and demonstrate that he's
living by the scout oath and law.
I'll also
tell him if the behavior doesn't improve,
he could be dismissed from the
troop. Any other
ideas or guidance you have would be
much appreciated. Well, let's
take a look at this. First of
all, let's deal with the bullying behavior.
Let's examine
that for a moment. I think
it's pretty easy to conclude that the
scouts are not paying attention.
they haven't been able to
get by any other means. They're confused
about it, as we are. They aren't
really sure why they're doing what
they're doing. they just know that
when they do it, somebody is finally
paying attention to them. They're also
looking for the approval of their
fellow scouts and their peers. They
think
that the best way to do this is
by showing how superior they are or
exerting their power over younger scouts
and they are imposing in our
minds: separate the behavior from
the scout. I really
doubt that any boy who is of scout
age gets up one morning and decides: you
know what? I'm going to try this bullying
thing out so I can be, get a
lot of attention and be popular. They're in
this kind of tumultuous, difficult time
in their lives. They may
feel as though they're not getting attention.
it's not necessarily that they're
making a conscious choice to act
the way that they do. it's just what
happens. You're going
to get a lot of attention from the
scout and that's an important step because,
going forward, you're going to
need to sit down and address this pretty
directly, and we're going to address it
from understanding that there's a
lot of potential for good in this
scout that is being misdirected at
bullying because he just hasn't
figured out any better way to
get attention at this point. So, as
soon as possible, yeah, have a
conference with the scout. just sit down
and address the problem and attempt
to do this without unloading on
the scout or putting him in
the position where he's going to get defensive against
an accusation. So I
would ask him to sit down and I'd say something like:
it's come to my attention that there's
been some troublesome behavior lately that
I would have to call out bullying.
to tell you the truth, I've seen
you do this with some of your fellow scouts. I
want to talk to you about it because I'm
confident that you're a good scout and
they have a lot of potential, but for
some reason it's not
coming through right now. so can you
tell me what you may have done or
said that makes me conclude that
you may have a bullying
problem and the scout may or
may not give you a direct answer. and you
know I wouldn't be surprised if he
felt very defensive about it and was
not willing to have this kind of discussion.
and you know I've had
these types of discussions with scouts and
sometimes they just clam up
and they're not willing to talk to you
about it. but you really want to
discuss this problem behavior. so the
first step is, of course you would
like the scout to be able to talk with
you about it and counsel, but they
might not want to do that. so the
next step would be to say:
listen, you know you and
I can discuss and resolve this, or I'm
going to have to get your parents to join
the discussion. so it's
really kind of your choice. if you
want to discuss this with me now, that's fine.
if you don't want to discuss this with
me, I'll just have to have your parents
about it. that may help him understand that
this is something that we're
going to end up having to deal with and
may not want to
have his parents involved in that type of discussion,
so he might discuss it with you once you
get going with this discussion, work your
way along without offering
much in the way of judgments
or evaluations. so I'm
asking him to answer the question: what may
you have done or said
that makes me conclude
that you're having a bullying problem right
now, that you're bullying your fellow
scouts? let's get him to
come up with something. so let's say that
he comes up with an example of bullying
behavior. you repeat that back to
him and you say so. you're telling me that
you feel like this is bullying
another scout, right?
so I'm not making a
judgment about that myself. he's telling me
what he believes bullying behavior
is. and then the next step would
be to ask what points
of the scout law bear on
the situation that you've
described and help him figure out which
ones those are and ask them to
explain those points to you
to see if you have a shared understanding of
what trustworthy or loyal or helpful
or friendly is- and there's
a pretty good discussion right there- making
sure that you have a shared understanding
of what those points of the
scout law mean. so we've separated the
behavior- you see
what I'm saying- from the scout. we're both
sitting there looking at
the behavior, not judging
whether the scouts a good barrister or
bad person or anything like that. we're
judging the behavior separate from
who the scout is,
and we want to throw in as much
encouragement as possible into this
discussion to build him up, you know,
because really, like I
said before, he may,
he's not making necessarily a
conscious decision to be
this way. this is, this
is a bid for attention and it's
working and this is what he's up to. I would
tell him that we want you
to be in scouts. we like
having you around, you're a
good guy, you have a lot of potential, but we
really can't have that kind of behavior, and I
can tell now, after we've
discussed it for a while- that you
understand that and from now on, you'll be
careful to
obey the scout oath and law. I know
you're capable of doing that and I'll
be here to talk to if you
run into problems with that. so let's
make sure that, before we get
up from the table here, that we
have an agreement between you
and I that you
understand what the problem is, you understand
how to fix it and that's
obeying the scout oath and law, and then
if you run into any problems with it- because you
know this is this could
be really challenging- so if
you run into any problems with it, we'll be
able to talk to each other, just like
we are now within this
little counseling session. the idea
is that we're getting
the scout to set their own
standard of behavior based on
the scout oath and law. we don't
want to dictate that to them. we want
to encourage them to discover
that for themselves and adopt
that standard as their
behavior. now the
last thing I would tell him as a
part of this conversation is: you
know, before we go any further, it's up
to me to tell you that if
this bullying behavior continues, I'm gonna
have to involve your parents in this
and all of us will have to sit
down and talk. and I'll tell you exactly what
will be said in that
discussion is that we've talked
about this, we've been working on this, but the
behavior is still occurring. and until
you guys have worked on this, you can't
be involved in scouts. until your
parents assure me that you
won't be behaving like
that anymore. so remember,
when we began the conversation with these
guys, we gave them the option: the two
of us can talk about it or I'm
gonna have to involve your parents in this
discussion. if he decides that that's
what he wants to do. if he
doesn't want to talk to you about it, then you
need to follow up with the parents and the
scout all together at once
and you say: look, he's not
interested in talking to me about this. we're having
some problems with bullying behavior. so I
have to leave it to you to sort
this out. and until you've talked
with your son and he's
agreed that he's not
going to behave this way again, he can't
really be a part of any
scouting activities. I think
he's a good scout, I think
he has a lot of potential, but you
understand my position. I just
can't have this kind of behavior. so I'm
gonna ask you to talk to your son and see
what you can do to fix it. that might
take an hour or a week or a month- however long
you need to do it, but we'll
accept him back on your word once you've
dealt with this at home, that we're
not going to have a problem with bullying
behavior from here on out. so I'm
not suspending the scout. I'm not
punishing the scout. I'm not
using any kind of corrective discipline with the
scout. in that
particular instance, where I'm
speaking with his parents, I am
telling the parents: we don't
have this kind of behavior in scouting. you have
to deal with it. he won't
deal with it with me and take
whatever time you need to deal with it, but until
then he simply can't be active because he's
behaving poorly to solve
the problem. because, as
I've said many, many times before, scouters do
not use corrective discipline and we
do not use punishment. that's a
parent's prerogative. they are
made aware of the situation. they apply
it as they see fit. here's what
I would not do. I would
not get a bunch of other adults involved in
this, because it's going to tend just to
muddy the waters. I want
to work with the scout and his family. naturally, whenever
I have a discussion with the
scout, it's going to be in the full view of other
adults and I
may ask another adult to sit in with me, not necessarily
to put their oar in, but just
to listen to what's said, so that
I have somebody you know who I
can talk to after I've
talked with the scout to make
sure that I got it right. so what
we're doing when we're counseling with scouts is an
essential aspect of character development in scouting.
we're establishing
an inner standard based on
the scout oath and law and we
don't want to substitute our judgment with our
spirit. so when
it comes time to sign the requirement for that,
you need
to talk to the scout and ask
them to judge their own attitudes and actions,
and when
you're doing that, you're further
addressing and developing this internal
standard based on the scout oath and law.
if you
don't agree with their assessment of things, then you
need to talk about why and you
need to agree to a series of steps or benchmarks
where you're both going to be satisfied with your
environment. we would
never want to use advancement as a
punishment or an incentive to affect
behavior, because we
don't need to. scouts already
understand the incentives involved and
we don't use corrective punishment.
that's just
not something that scouts do. we use
advancement to build character in a
sense of honor, by taking
advantage of the opportunity to have
scouts assess themselves according to
their own developing inner standard, and you'll
find, most of the time scouts are
going to be a lot harder on themselves
than you are. so let
me review this very quickly. if we
have a scout who has a problem with bullying
behavior, we need to address it directly. we don't
need to wait, and the
way that we address it is: we have a discussion with them.
we say: look, this is the behavior I'm seeing.
do you understand what kind
of behavior it is? can you
explain it to me? can you
tell me how the scout oath and law
bears on this type of behavior and what
you need to do to fix it? in this
discussion, support and
encouragement, because we see potential in
the scout for good. if the
scout does not want to discuss this with us
or the behavior continues after
the discussion, we're going
to have to involve the parents. if the
scouts totally resistant to
dealing with us, it's going to be up to the reparents
to resolve the behavior problem and
then we'll take their word that that's
been resolved and we'll
have the scout back actively involved. well, listen,
I hope that helps. these behavior
difficulties can be
really really challenging, especially the
first couple of times that you
go through them, but you'll get better at it
and I think understanding the principles
involved will help kind of
calm your own personal reaction to
it and separate the behavior
from the scout counsel. help
them bring their
judgment into it. don't substitute your
judgment for it. bring their
judgment into it and you'll begin helping
them develop character by
calling on an inner
standard that's developing in them. hey, if
you have a question for me that you'd
like to have addressed, I don't
put them all on the
podcast. I do it only with your
permission, and there's many questions
like this that are a little tricky, so we
we keep names and
locations out of it, but you
can get in touch with me. it's pretty easy to do and you're
going to find out how to do that in just a moment. music. well,
thanks
for listening to this
254th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast. you
can keep in touch by reading
the blog at scoutmastercgcom, and you
can also sign up to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can join 1000 other
mobile scouters who have the scoutmaster cg app
on their mobile devices, and you
can get the app on google play or in
the itunes app store. you can
experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom, as
they are, through the
vast panorama of social media
outlets. join the nearly 7700
folks who like
scoutmaster blog on facebook, tweet along
with the chorus of 1200 tweeters on
twitter and, of course,
you can pin the poultry tuna's pictures, proffered publicly,
with 1900 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest and
watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube. or join the 400
odd folks who form
the exclusive scoutmastercg circle on
google plus. if
you're one of those people who
just can't face facebook, twitter makes you
better. you've no interest in pinterest. you don't
put the you in youtube. you're a
minus when it comes to google plus. that's okay,
bunkie, there's lots of you out there,
it's fine. zoom into
the late 90s and send
me an email. you can email me your
comments and questions and your
wild ideas at clark at
scoutmastercgcom. that's C-L-A-R-K-E.
at scoutmastercgcom,
the scoutmaster
blog and the scoutmaster podcast
and all the other crazy stuff we do
are not official publications of anybody
in particular, especially the
Boy Scouts of America, nor are
they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America, or any
other scouting organization for that matter. because here
we are. it's just me talking into
a microphone trying to
lend a hand to scout leaders and have
a little bit of fun as we do so. speaking of
which, here is our founder, Sir Robert
Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck
to you and good camping. I thank
you, sir. until next
time, everyone.